la page culture comme chaque mercredi
avec aelliia de ici Aurélia ce soir vous
allez nous parler cinéma avec vos
invités des organisateurs de festival
des directeurs de salle également qui
vont nous rejoindre dans un instant
juste le temps tout d'abord de se rendre
du côté de Versailles vous le savez si
vous étiez avec nous hier l'Opéra royal
favorise le messena pour se développer
c'est même en dehors de la billetterie
son unique système de ressources pour
financer les spectacles vivants le
cercle des mesn qui s'est réuni hier à
Versailles Catherine zulato et Guillaume
camps pour les
explications dernière répétition de
Platé de Rameau joué à l'Opéra Royal de
Versailles dans ce théâtre tant voulu
par Louis XIV s'enchaîne des spectacles
tout au long de l'année ce petit
chef-d'œuvre d'astuces et de grâce fait
tout en bois ne perçoit aucune
subvention ses financements l'Opéra
royal lestient des recettes d'entrée
mais surtout des méenes le cercle de
l'Opéra c'est donc son nom regroupe 12
messenes le cercle existe depuis 2009 il
vient de s'ouvrir aux PME et au TPE aux
toutes petites entreprises c'est la
possibilité de faire des choses qu'on
aurait peut-être pas pu faire alors ça
peut être acheter un Clavin dont on a
besoin pour l'opéra ça peut être
financer un spectacle qu'on aurait pas
pu financer cette année parce qu'on
aurait pas eu les moyens tout seul le
ticket d'entrée pour intégrer le cercle
des mesenes est fixé à 4000 € et peut
atteindre 45000 € mais parle d'argent
dans ce domaine c'est toujours disons
déplacé il est un intérêt fiscal mais
enfin c'est pas l'intérêt majeur
l'intérêt majeur c'est quand même de
participer à ce que notre patrimoine
vive et vive bien le retour il se fait
en en comment dirais-je en en en
ambiance en en contact en richesse de
contact et puis et puis quand on est
amoureux on compte pas comme on dit hein
donc alors ne parlons pas de de
d'avantage fiscal c'est
c'est c'est c'est sal laerie sur le
gâteau quoi grâce à l'argent des
mescenes l'opéra royale de Versailles a
pu s'offrir une création de Denis
podalides d'autres événements seront
proposés à l'occasion de l'année le
nôtre qui va occuper la vie du château
pendant tout
2013 après l'opéra le cinéma je vous le
disais avec trois invités Franck Villet
bonsoir président organisateur du
Festival International du Film courage
Jouan Josas également Jean Fuger bonsoir
directeur du cinéma la Barbacan c'est
ben et puis beroir trignier pardon
responsable du cinéma Les Yeux d'Elsa
c'est à sa-ciè l'école bonsoir à tous
les trois bonsir bonsoir Aélia et oui
donc nous recevons et on avons nous
avons beaucoup de chance ce soir trois
experts du cinéma donc chacun d'entre
vous vous allez nous parler de votre
programmation
respective on va commencer avec Fran
Villet puisque et bien dès ce weekend
donc dès vendredi même a lieu donc le
Festival International du Film Court à
Jouan Josas alors dites-nous c'est une
4e édition queles sont les nouveautés 4e
édition déjà et on a 34 films en
compétition et les nouveautés il y aura
notamment une leçon de cinéma qu'on
installe le vendredi soir pour faire
découvrir le le court-métrage donc c'est
pas que la projection c'est pas que de
la projection on a voulu vraiment
apporter autre chose que de la simple
projection au public voilà pour leur
donner envie de B de s'intéresser au
courage pu pe interagir ou oui le pu PE
peut poser des questions il y aura
vraiment une interaction entre les
invités et et le public et puis je crois
que dans les nouveautés vous avez aussi
une partie cinécte C voilà ça c'est le
c'est pour le dimanche où la journée un
peu plus réservé au aux enfants en tout
les cas au jeune public il a un cinécte
avec Berti soulier qui est une compteuse
et qui interviendra pareil en
interactivité avec les enfants elle
interviendra sur les les courtmétrages
donc son compte
aura un rapport avec les les films qui
seront diffusés et donc l'idée c'est de
pouvoir expliquer peut-être de manière
plus simple plus simple façon ludique
expliquer vraiment pareil ce qu'est le
court-métrage et amener une histoire un
peu plus facilement que une simple
projection d'un film et vous avez deux
deux types de compétition une
compétition officielle oui voilà une
compétition jeune public voilà alors
est-ce que vous avez eu des difficultés
à constituer les membres du jury euh oui
toujours c'est toujours à la dernière au
dernier moment parce que il y a des
problèmes de de de planning d'emploi du
temps pour poures pour ces invités donc
on aura Catherine benigi qui est actrice
et Julien Courbet acteur aussi voilà on
aura également une productrice un autre
acteur donc il y a des personnalités et
voilà il y a des personnalités on essaie
de mélanger un petit peu les les les les
fonctions personnalités ou ou gens un
peu moins connus même dans dans les
fonctions acteurs technicien donc an
Bertrand productrice et Thomas Fauch qui
est acteur et magicien alors en
compétition il y aura un film qui
s'appelle ce n'est pas un film de cowboy
on va regarder sa bande annonce et juste
pour information ce film est également
en compétition pour les Césars donc on
regarde tout de
suite demander un truc tu as vu toi le
film à la télé hier soir Mountain non
j'ai pas le droit de regarder la télé ma
mère trouve que c'est
BR para super bon West c'est pas
westernb et tout c'est un truc
nouveau c'est
quoi
genre
voilà pour cette bande annonce de ce
court-métrage en compétition vous l'avez
dit pour les Césars exactement euh alors
on va rappeler les dates du festival ça
démarre vendredi donc le 22 jusqu'au 24
jusqu'à dimanche jusqu'à dimanche voilà
d'accord est-ce que euh dans dans le
public que vous attendez
euh qu'est-ce que vous pouvez leur dire
là pour qu'il viennent vous vous voir ce
weekend et bien sil ne connaissent pas
le le format du court-métrage c'est
l'occasion de venir découvrir vraiment
des des j'allais dire des petites perles
oui c'est vrai qu'on a essayé de
dénicher des des des courtmétrages voilà
qui nous ont intéressé évidemment qui
nous ont touché au niveau du du sujet
euh voilà ensuite c'était une sélection
un peu difficile he vous m'aviez dit 800
861 film on a on a reçu pour au final
vous avez visionné on a visionné oui
1861 d'accord avec une durée moyenne
pour les courtmétrag de euh nous on
limite à 20 minutes j'espère qu'il
faisait pas tous 20 minutes parce
beaucoup au deelà de 15 mais bon vous
avez des journées bien remplies voilà on
a eu des journées bien remplies et euh
voilà donc si pour au final avoir retenu
combien de 34 34 en sélection officielle
donc euh 34 films inédits on a une série
une sélection best of aussi 2012 avec
les films primés l'année dernière euh
pour compléter avec la leçon de cinéma
voilà et donc s'ils aiment le
court-métrage et bien c'est le moment de
venir vendredi et samedi il y a des
intervenants des invités euh voilà des
rencontres professionnelles un partage
entre le public et et les professionnels
c'est important les professionnels qui
les programmateur de salle vous en
pensez quoi des court-métrages d'une
manière générale est-ce que vous êtes
amateur client de court-métrage euh ouif
che nous on on est euh on est adhérant à
l'agence du court-métrage qui est une
une association qui euh qui soutient le
court-métrage en France et qui donc nous
donne la possibilité à des coûts euh un
peu moindre en tout cas de d'avoir accès
à a des court-métrages à tout un
catalogue donc qui est négocié et qui
nous permett nous de présenter un
court-métrage chaque semaine dans notre
salle devant un film un peu au hasard et
au choix on essaie de trouver des
thématiques entre les les grand F de
voir des courtmétrage projetés dans des
salles de cinéma ça reste assez assez
rare c'est devenu plus rare en tout cas
c'est devenu plus rare effectivement
malheureusement malheureusement parce
que c'est une magnifique école et une
magnifique manière d'aborder le d'autres
formes de cinéma c'est bien dommage oui
exactement c'est c'est un genre enfin
c'est c'est un format qui est cantonné à
la télévision à des horaires très tard
et dans nos salles ben voilà quelqu fois
on a bon programme qu'est-ce qui fait un
bon court-métrage alors le critère qui
sera essentiel pour la
sélection bonne histoire une bonne
technique un bon jeu de comédien après
ça il y a une part de subjectivité quand
on fait la la sélection évidemment mais
voilà ce sont les trois principaux
critères pour retenez le scénario le jeu
d' scénario le jeu d'acteur et et la
technique au niveau de l'image et le
résultat global en fait le résultat
global voilà après les moyens qu'ils ont
eu pour le faire nous ça on retient pas
ça en en jeu c'est vraiment le le
résultat qui compte d'accord et vous
Bertrand Pinier vous nous proposez aussi
une
programmation un peu inédite dans votre
cinéma un peu particulière et oui
puisque tout va se dérouler sur une nuit
oui c'est ça oui c'est l'idé voilà
puisqu'on a des gens qui viennent au
cinéma de manière un peu large là on a
essayer de de faire une sorte
d'événement voilà de de faire venir les
gens tous ensemble à un moment donné
toute une nuit vous avez choisi le TH on
a choisi le thème des serial killer
parce que parce que un indice on le voit
pas bien à l'antenne peut-être on l'a vu
tout à l'heure vous avez le t-shirt pour
comoui comme ça on le verrait bien en
fait oui on a choisi le SER killer parce
que parce que ça tient réveillé les
sérial killer évidemment oui parce qu'il
faut tenir réveillé jusqu'à 5h du matin
quand même c'est ça c'est l'idée après
on pas obligé on n pas obligé c'est
confortable une salle de cinéma pour
dormir aussi mais je pense que ces films
là ne permettront pas de dormir en fait
alors dites-nous quelle quelle fiche
quel film pardon ser à l'affiche alors à
21h le premier film c'est God Bless
America un film indépendant américain
qui est sorti il y a quelques mois et
qui raconte l'odyssée de d'un d'un homme
en face terminale et d'une jeune
lycéenne qui on tous les deux marre de
la média culture américaine et qui vont
donc se mettre à canarder un peu partout
et en particulier les stars les stars de
la télééalité alors justement désolé de
parler ça sur un plateau de télé mais
dites-nous quels sont les les trois
autres films et puis on va regarder un
extrait du alors le second film c'est
maniaque euh qui est une un remake d'un
film de 84 qui avait été assez marquant
en tout cas moi qui m'avait marqué quand
je l'ai découvert un peu un peu jeune
peut-être avec eligia wood réalisé par
Franck calfoun et Alexandre haard le
troisème film donc c'est c'est
l'histoire d'un Salal
killer qui a des tendances à scalper les
gens en fait voilà non ça c'est le le
deuxième maniaque le trisème film Malcom
c'est beaucoup plus drôle c'est une
sorte de cette arrivée près de chez vous
pour ceux con découper les gens c'est
pas très très très drôle on est sur une
thématique ouais c'est pas le but en
tout cas tu as du deuxème le deuxème est
interdit au moins de 16 ans et il est
vraiment voilà t rrouve dans un registre
très loin de ce qu'il avait pu faire
avec le Seigneur des anneau ex
exactement tout à fait oui mais mais
voilà qui apparemment est un le bon
acteur pour le rôle et ensuite les
autres films sont simplement interdits
au moins de 12 déconseillé au moins de
12 ans et c'est des films qui sont
beaucoup plus sur un sur un un versant
comique en fait enfin voilà qui traitent
les choses d'une manière plutôt comique
donc le 3è c'est donc Malcolm à 1h du
matin donc là on sera le 3 mars le
dimanche 3 mars et c'est l'histoire d'un
d'un intellectuel américain enfin new
yorkaais qui trouve que New York n'est
pas assez accessible n'est plus assez
accessible aux artistes et qui décide de
faire baisser les prix de l'immobilier
en tuant des gens puisque du coup
évidemment ça devrait faire baisser les
prix de l'immobilier ce qui est une
théorie un peu bizarre mais qui donne un
film très drôle et et le tout dernier
film c'est touriste un film anglais de
de Ben Whitley qui est sorti également
il y a quelques semaines et qui raconte
l'histoire voir une sorte de de road
movie à travers l'Angleterre de d'un
d'un couple qui va tuer par accident et
finalement y prendre un peu de plaisir
au fur à mesure
voilà alors on va peut-être regarder
dans la partie un peu un peu comique God
Bless America cétait un peu votre coup
de cœur je crois ouais ou oui alors on
regarde tu t'appelles comment Steven
Clark tu peux nous dire ce que tu vas
chanter Steven Clark c'est comme si la
presse lui avait donné carte blanche et
qu'il pouvait faire les adoles avait été
arrêté après avoir mis le feu à SDF
après la pub dans Villain
fille une tumeur de cette taille là est
est vraiment dangereuse vous avez de la
famille
ou c'est une
urgence salut je m'appelle Chloé
j'habite à Virginia Beach et je suis
très populaire dans mon lycée parce que
je suis jolie4 c'est le jour le plus
important de ma vie é es en train de le
en l'air c'est moi qui Fa Bou e
pervers tu te crois maliner les petites
lycéennes tu fais pas un geste et tu la
boucl si vous voulez la voiture prenezla
M par M paschet làb je sais c'est
vraiment
tragique est-ce que tu viens de tuer
Chloé ah c'est trop bien c'est excellent
pour un début tu veux des suggestions
c'est qui tes prochaines victime une
sœur Kardashian les gens qui disent MGA
et géant les personnes qui disent stop
là les gens qui portent des
bisou quoi ça sert d'avoir une
civilisation si les personnes qui la
titue ne voit aucun intérêt à être un
minimum
civilisé God Bless America pour cette
nuit un sérial killer du côté de votre
cinéma ce sera le 2 mars juste une
petite question tout de même qui
m'interroge depuis tout à l'heure là le
t-shirt maniaque vous le mettez dans la
rue aussi oui bien sûr ça interpelle pas
les gens non pas du tout en j'ai pas eu
de remarque désagréable en tout cas très
bien personne vous évite non tout va
bien non pas du tout très bien très joli
T-shirt
alors Jean Fuger vous allez également
nous parler de votre programmation qui
va se dérouler sur plusieurs mois
plusieurs semaines on va faire un lien
quand même peut-être avec la partie
serérial killer tout du moins je dirais
pour un des films puisqueen fait vous
votre programmation vous allez nous nous
en parler l'idée c'est de projeter
uniquement des films sur bobine 35 mm et
ce qui va préparer je dirais notre
deuxième thématique tout à l'heure notre
échange autour justement de la fin de de
ces projections bobines et pour
l'arrivée du tout numérique tout
numérique à gagné finalement exactement
voilà c'était pas forcément gagné il y a
une dizaines d'années effectivement
c'est un choix particulier alors
effectivement sur les semaines qui vont
venir sur les mois qui vont qui vont
nous séparer de ce passage au numérique
qui va se passer pour nous tout début
juillet on va travailler sur des
thématiques une thématique tombe autour
de une quinzaine autour de la comédie
une quinzaine ensuite une semaine autour
de
l'espionnage une une semaine de
science-fiction et enfin un moment qu'on
app qu'on appelle barbac can un jeune
mot bon qui est là pour accrocher le le
regard pour proposer aux gens
effectivement de choisir de sélectionner
dans une liste proposée ce qui les a
marqué sur ces 10 dernières années dans
le cinéma voilà et tout ça projeté en 35
minutes voilà et alors je vous parlais
de lien avec syia killer mais on est
plus sur la partie comédie parce que
vous allez projeter notamment la cité de
la peur exact on va regarder un petit
extrait on peut pas on peut pas passer à
côté on va regarder cette extrait cette
bande annonce de la cité de la peur on
rappelle les autres films aussi à
l'affiche le dîner de con aussi par
exemple ou
encoreé voilà on va regarder alors la
cité de la
peur le festival de Cann l'événement
médiatique que le monde entier nous
envie alors vous allez être content
parce que l'année dernière c'est
Nicoletta qui avit votre
chambre mais le monde du cinéma est
parfois une jongle bien cruelle madame
je n'écrirai rien sur ce film c'est une
merde jusqu'à où on peuton aller pour
promotionniser un film jusqu'à le
meurtre jusqu'à
où le film de les Nuls vous enchantera
par ces dialogues Ji c'est quoi Cachem
c'est du coton prière voiture cétait une
Peugeot parce que moi je su acteur etes
image
chyante c'est unû de pomme de terre
sur si vous avez aimé Jurassic Park la
leçon de piano et le fugitif et ben nous
aussi on a bien
aimé de la peur qui sera projeté version
pellicule véritablement pas encore de T
numérique cette magie de la lumière nous
en parlions tout à l'heure effectivement
les projectionistes pour c'est la magie
de la lumière ce travail c'est le tout
numérique c'est trop froid c'est trop
déjà adopté vont nous en parler
peut-être mais voilà juste pour le
plaisir moi j'ai bien envie qu'on
regarde un extrait d' SOS fantô vous
voulez un autre extrait encore bon et
ben alors si tout le monde est prêt
regardons cet extrait SOS fantô aussi
projeté du côté du cinéma de
Ben des
fantômes allô SOS
fantôme ils sont palpables ah oui
implaca chez vous
indélogeable un client youi
SOS fantôme vousz pas vu un revenant
trois hommes capturent un fantôme
impossible à tuer ta petite amie habite
un joli duplexe au beau milieu de la
foire au fantôme désirez-vous ce corps
qui
brûle voilà SOS fantôme 1984 exactement
date de sortie ça ça nous rénit pas il
paraît ou
bon alors on continue donc en effet donc
en lien avec cette projection bobine et
bien tout simplement donc pour rappeler
à nos téléspectateurs que à compter de
cet été vous passez vous nous passons au
num au cinéma de Ben tout numérique mais
tout simplement donc pour Rael
aujourd'hui les sorties se font
quasiment en tout numérique donc c'est
la raison pour laquelle les cinémas sont
obligés de s'équiper de cette manière et
alors nous avons ici Bertrand Pignier
qui qui va pouvoir peut-être nous donner
un un retour d'expérience puisque vous
ça fait à peu près un peu plus d'un an
je crois que votre salle est équipée au
tout numérique alors dites-nous
aujourd'hui bah quels sont les les
avantages et peut-être les inconvénients
de de ce Nau forat euh bah les les les
avantages c'est tout simplement qu'on a
on arrive à avoir accès au films tout
simplement puisqueen fait maintenant les
les les distributeurs ne ne tirent
quasiment plus de copie 35 mm que de
manière très exceptionnelle et dans des
contextes très particuliers euh on est
aujourd'hui à un taux d'équipement en
France qui approche les 99 % donc voilà
le le 35 mm c'est pas qu'il n'a plus son
sa place mais tout simplement dans dans
l'actualité dans le flux quotidien de de
la de la programmation les les les
transports de film les transferts de
film se font ça facilite dis dur pour
vous cet aspect technique de ça enfin on
était habitué avant à travailler avec
des pellicules il a fallu apprendre à
changer de de manière de travailler mais
les les supports qu'on diffuse enfin
voilà ce qu'on ce qu'on diffuse ça reste
la même chose c'est alors du coup un
support pour plusieurs types de
communication aussi que ce soit des
informations de la publicité ou du film
tout va être sur même support ex alor
oui voilà moi nous ce qu'on essaie de
faire enfin on essaie du coup de
d'utiliser le le numérique comme on ne
pouvait pas utiliser le 35 mm le 35 mm
nous permettait de passer des film des
publicités quand on nous en livrait mais
il nous permettait pas à nous sal de
produire des éléments communication ou
d'information au public et cetera le
numérique nous le permet puisque on a
tous des ordinateurs qui sont maintenant
suffisamment performants pour pouvoir
travailler la vidéo et donc on du coup
notre choix à nous c'est de dans les
premières parties de programme d'avoir
des informations sur nos programmations
sur nos événements et éventuellement sur
les événements de nos partenaires
puisque on diffuse en ce moment la bande
annonce du festival de de jou en Josas
depuis 2 semaines maintenant ce qu'on
aurait pas pu faire en 35 mm travailler
en lien aussi tous les deux je crois sur
la partie cinécte sur cinécte ou oui ou
exactement et là le support numérique
devient intéressant parce que c'est un
support plus propice je dirais à au côté
pédagogique ou à l'éducatif alors par
rapport au par rapport au cinécte pas
nécessairement mais sur sur tout ce qui
est le le travail avec les scolaires oui
ça nous permet en fait de voilà
lorsqu'on accueille les enfants dans une
salle de leur diffuser la fiche du film
de pouvoir les interroger sur la fiche
avant qu'il voit le film ou après
éventuellement de revenir sur des extras
toutes ces chosesl en fait c'est des
choses qui sont possibles maintenant
avec le numérique parce qu'on est sur un
seul équipement et qu'on peut très
facilement y brancher un ordinateur donc
il y a que du positif vous êtes rassuré
vous êtes vous étitre pas inquiet ceou
non pas du tout mais c'est vrai
effectivement de toute manière
maintenant j'ai encore appris que hier
paramoun a annoncé qu'il ne sortirait
plus rien bien sûr en argentique en 35
mm mais que même il retirait son
catalogue tout les 35 mm donc il les
gardent en stock mais il ils ne sont
plus accessibles pour une diffusion donc
on profite nous de ces derniers instants
pour avoir quelques films encore avec
cette petit bémol je crois quand même
euh sur la partie euh bah le métier du
du projectionniste du coup qui est en
pleine mutation oui c'est enfin c'est
c'est le second bémol moi je je voudrais
revenir aussi sur ce bémol des films qui
vont disparaître hein il y a toute une
partie des films tout toute une partie
des catalogues qui ne vont plus être
accessibles la cité de la peur est un
exemple frappant hein le film existe en
35 mm il est pas dit que le distributeur
fasse des des des disques durs de ce
film c'est c'est son choix donc il est
possible que bientôt ce film ne puisse
plus être diffusé dans les salles de
cinéma c'est un investissement réel
aussi sur le plan financier
véritablement va falloir vous équiper ça
coûte très cher comment ça va se passer
pour vous nous on a budgeté à peu près
80000 € tout de même voilà sur lequel
effectivement il pourrait y avoir une
participation significative de tutelle
du CNC sur en avance et cetera mais
c'est un cût extrêmement
important surtout pour des salles comme
les nôtres qui sont des salles de cinéma
diraisje occasionnel moins réguli que
çaci ou ou d'autres lieux et ça impose
effectivement cela bon mais d'un côté ça
ça permet de suivre effectivement ses
évolutions ces possibilités
voilà voilà ça permettra de développer
aussi d'autres prenez ça avec
philosophie malgré tout mais il faudra
célébrer C faut le fêter mais c'est vrai
qu'on profitera de ces momentsl aussi
pour inviter les gens à monter en cabine
pour qu'ils voient le les particularités
la richesse la é aussi de ces
instruments de
projection de ce qui se passe dans la
cabin cette histoire là est-ce que vous
allez garder vos je pense qu'on va le
garder on va essayer de l'exposer en bas
voilà comme d'autres théâtres d'autres
lieux le font mais nous enfin dans notre
salle le 35 mm est toujours présent on a
diffusé encore il y a peu de temps un
programme de court-métrage en 35 minutes
parce qu'il est pas disponible en
numérique et et la machine tourne très
bien et quand je présente moi aux
enfants quand je les leur fait visiter
la cabine je leur parle quasiment pas du
projecteur numérique je leur montre ce
que un projecteur de 35 mm puisque la
machine en elle-même parle visuellement
on comprend comment elle fonctionne un
projecteur numérique c'est une boîte
noir avec un objectif d'un côté et un
ordinateur à côté donc c'est c'est aussi
important de conserver le 35 mm pour
pouvoir expliquer ce qu'est le le cinéma
au dernière séance en 35 mm du côté de
votre cinéma dans votre cinéma à ben on
va rappeler les grandes dates les grands
moments les temps forts le calendri mars
quinzaine comédie au mois de ensuite ça
va s'enchaîner semaine de l'espionnage
Barbacan donc au début mai voilà et ça
ça sera la sélection choisie et retenue
par le public par les spectateurs VO
votre sélection Aelia SOS fantôme ou si
tu es de la peur ou il va falloir
choisir ah oui c'est difficile moi je
crois que j'irai aux deux en tout cas
vousz au deux c'est de voter dans ce
CASL faut on peut passer aussi par le
site internet de la Barbacan oui qui va
s'afficher on l' voilà et du côté des
spectateurs justement nous sommes allés
poser cette question quel est le film
qui vous a le plus marqué dans les
salles de cinéma ces 20 dernières années
on n'est pas remonté trop trop loin non
plus nous intéresse on va écouter
quelquesunes des réponses recueillies
aujourd'hui d'berman avec Vincent
Cassell et Monica Bellucci et c'est un
film très très bon un peu trop violent
mais super super bon Shutter Island
était vraiment bien le film avec
DiCaprio j'ai bien d'aimer le film du
les vacances du Kobu parce que c un film
assez drôle le premier qui me vient à
l'esprit c'est bienvenu chez leschti
pour quelle raison parce que ça fait
très longtemps que j'avais Paris comme
ça c'est intouchable la ligne verte
parce que parce que l'histoire est
sublime c'est sublimement joué et puis
ça change un peu de l'ordinaire Danse
avec les loups 92 il y a pas le fction
il réservoir dog il y a le Star Wars
épisode 3 moi c'est in touchable parce
que j'ai trouvé ça touchant parce que
c'était drôle et parce que j'aime bien
au mars en fait donc ces 20 dernières
années effectivement là c'était
peut-être un peu compliqué sur le
dernier des micro trottoir s'il y a un
film que vous deviez retenir ces 20
dernières années chacun je pas ou là là
euh c'est difficile oui c'est difficile
ouis doberman là qui l'a cité le premier
c'est un bon choix mais c'est pas le je
je vais m'abstenir sinon va
influencé ah c'est très très compliqué
il y a tellement de films magnifiques
enfin ça paraît être un peu manère
émotion au cinéma une belleou une belle
émotion au cinéma en tout cas dans une
salle ma dernière belle émotion au
cinéma c'est de Hurlevent voilà qui qui
a un film de andreé Arnold absolument
magnifique et qui là en l'occurrence a
été tourné en 35 mm et est passé au
numérique magnifiquementou voilà nous
parlons cinéma ce soir Aurélien un
rappel le festival du court-métrage et
puis les programmations de sallesen Al
donc le festival du court-métrage c'est
vendredi jusqu'à dimanche vendredi
jusqu'à dimanche à joué en Josas avec 34
films en compétition une leçon de cinéma
cinécon ciné quiz voilà une
programmation pour les pour le jeune
public voilà et la mairie de Jan Josas
qui qui s'est investi à fond dans cette
qui s'est invvestit à fond dans cet
événement franis brjo et que je salue
merci tout fait du côté du cinéma la
Barb canaben donc une programmation
globalement sur de de mois à peu près
des thématiques
comédie je pas dans la nostalie voilà
des retour et puis le bonheur de voir
encore ces films sur un grand écran et
la télé ne remplacera désolé jamais
effectivement cette richesse et du côté
du cinéma de saint-cire les yeux d'Elsa
c'est le 2 mars une nuit entière
consacrée donc à quatre films sérial
killer de 21h à 5h du matin pour les
plus courageux God Bless America
maniaque Malcolm un film tout petit film
qui qu'on voit pas mais qui est très
bien et touriste voilà avec des des quiz
des choses à gagner des choses à manger
aussi et ce
voilà 5 matin plus courageux il y aura
le petit- dééjeuner ah la soupe à
l'oignon à 5h du matin non je vais pas
opter pour la soupe à l'oignon mais il y
aura du café du thé et des et des
viennoiseau le film de la semaine pour
vous si on revent sur l'actualité de
cette semaine au cinéma il faut aller
voir quoi c'est une question piège c'est
une question piège et ben en tout cas
qu' retenu les spectateurs même chose
nous sommes allés à votre rencontre vous
le savez le mercredi vos sorties ciné
nous allons recueillir vos réactions à
l'issue des premières projections c'est
navrant c'est lamentable je conseillerai
à tout le monde de garder ses 10 € d'en
faire un meilleur usage disons que c'est
un petit peu de c'est un peu timide mais
bon j'ai bien aimé quelques parties du
film notamment quand ils sont dans le
Sud-Ouest mais bon c'est ça détend quoi
un petit peu c'est du John mlein quoi
c'est familial c'est un épisode familial
cette fois-ci mais bon c'est super c'est
c'est bien c'est distrayant le film
d'action qu'on attend le film d'action
américain avec je dirais beaucoup de
pifpaf et beaucoup de badabom pendant 1
heure et demi pas beaucoup de de temps
mort c'est spectaculaire et c'est
marrant c'est exactement ce qu'on attend
c'est un très beau film très beau
document qui nous ont fait voir oui
c'est très bien pour la survie des
abeilles justement ça pourrait
intéresser beaucoup de gens je pense
même ceux qui ne sont pas dans
l'apiculture on a beaucoup enfin on est
assez triste quand on voit l'apiculture
comment comment on la pratique
aujourd'hui notamment aux États-Unis
hein en France on est à l'agriculture
intensive et là-bas ils sont passés à
l'apiculture intensive c'est vraiment
une
désastreuse et on peut retenir dans ce
film c'est c'est pas les abeilles qu'on
entend volerin ce sont les dollars qui
volent là-bas ça m'a beaucoup intéressé
puisque j'été le voir parce que ça
m'intéressait au niveau de comment
c'était filmé comment ils avent fait
pour filmer ça puis que c'est façon
documentaire dans la forêt amazonienne
je
crois pour finir la page culture
l'agenda et oui un agenda spécial pour
les amateurs de musique et
principalement les instruments àordes
nous avons au pristhme d'élencour samedi
à 20h un concert de jazz avec entre
autres comme guitariste dans ce trio de
musiciens Noé enart et oui le digne
héritier de son aïul Django suivi
toujours à samedi pardon à La Verrière
donc un concert de de musique de pour
violon pardon avec de 16h à 17h les
auditions des élèves de l'école de
musique et de danse de la verrière et
ceux du conservatoire de morpa suivi à
20h30 d'un concert autour des violents
du musique du monde merci Aurélia
prochain point sur la culture avec vous
mercredi prochain même horaire et si
vous voulez revoir cette chronique
n'oubliez pas notre site internet vous
pourrez la retrouver dès demain matin
consultation gratuite et à la demande et
j'en profite aussi que vous pouvez
toujours laisser vos commentaires sur
nos différentes éditions sur Twitter
hashtag le 7 su est-ce que vous
connaissez Lorenzo non et ben vous allez
faire sa connaissance Lorenzo ce sera
presque la mascotte du prochain Salon de
l'Agriculture qui va s'ouvrir le 23
février Porte de Versailles à Paris
c'est un merinos un bélier merinos il a
4 ans 85 kg reportage rencontre avec
Lorenzo
àambouillet Lorenzo magnifique bélier de
race Minos de rambouillé se prépare pour
le Salon de l'Agriculture dès samedi et
durant 9 jours ce Mâ de 4 ans quittera
la Bergerie Nationale pour représenter
les ovins pour faire honneur à sa race
importé d'Espagne en
1786 il a eu droit à un soin particulier
la traditionnelle taille des onglons
comprendre sé de manucure et pédicure et
une tonte au mois d'août afin de
présenter une toison de 6 mois
irréprochable pour l'anecdote Lorenzo
qui tient son prénom d'un berger
retraité de la Bergerie Nationale
produit l'équivalent de 9000 km de fibbr
de laine chaque année le manteau qu'on
lui fait porter depuis le jours de sa
ton ça fait 6 mois à peu
près a pour but de d'éviter que des
impuretés viennent salir sa toison
notamment la poussière mais aussi toutes
les impur végétale le foin la paille
puisque il est il vit en bergerie donc
il y a forcément des des impuretés qui
pourrai venir souiller la toison le
travail des bergers s'est aussi porté
sur le comportement de Lorenzo le mouton
est un animal gréger habitué à vivre en
communauté pour parader au salon il a
donc découvert les balades en solitaire
et en laiss les premières sorties en
dehors du groupe ben pose souvent des
problèmes parce que l'animal s'inquiète
un peu bon faut l'habituer après on peut
pas être très familier avec un un un
bélier parce que il vient très vite euh
euh très vite assez Cabo euh assez têtu
avec ses 85 kg Lorenzo a beauorté le
prénom d'un humain il n'en reste pas
moins une bête de
caractère effectivement il a du
caractère Lorenzo rendez-vous Porte de
Versailles à Paris salon de
l'agriculture moi je vous retrouve
demain à 18h en direct bonne
soirée